ten days after a complete information
blackout the Indian government set up
four computers with internet access for
more than 200 journalists in a media
center it controls in Srinagar the
reporters make patiently until it's
letter Samar Latif who writes for the
Indian daily the Tribune says sometimes
he cues for hours just to email his
story and if he's lucky chat briefly
with his editor you had to stand in the
queue and read for them and then you
send the stories you don't get time to
like to wait there for the response of
the editors then you had to go back
again to the same computer and see
whether we were edited has approved the
story or the Indian government has
issued press passes to most journalists
in the past few days but access to the
Internet is tightly controlled and
freedom of movement largely restricted
to within Sri Nagar itself conditions
however have improved a little since the
first days of the lockdown imposed
earlier this month after New Delhi's
decision to revoke indian-administered
Kashmir autonomy first few days what we
are doing is trying and sitting near the
television set and trying and finding
out for what's happening
on August 13 the editor of the Kashmiri
Times filed a petition in India Supreme
Court against the communications
blackout the government is saying that
the people are happy everything is fine
people are coming out on the roads
let them tell us that they are indeed
happy desperate but if you can bring the
groover the newspapers lawyer and a
human rights activist says Kashmiri
journalists have had a particularly
tough time even in the silencing and
crippling of media what we see is the
targeted silencing of the Kashmiri
journalists we do not hear that voice at
all today it's been difficult for
journalists to report from straigh Nagar
the capital of India administered
Kashmir for the past two weeks a minute
on one of the phone booths opened by the
government was considered a luxury and
although some restrictions have been
lifted making it relatively easier to
file stories from the city the rest of
the valley remains mostly out of bounds
Ultra Bora
Zera New Delhi